[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
monday september 19th i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
joseph sullivan was the chief security
officer of uber back in 2016 when the
ride-hailing company experienced a
massive data breach
the names emails and phone numbers of
millions of riders were exposed along
with around 600 000 driver's license
numbers
a year later uber disclosed the breach
and said it paid the hackers one hundred
thousand dollars
to get paid the hackers were made to
sign a non-disclosure agreement saying
they'd destroyed the data
sullivan was fired from the company in
2017 and he's now on trial for how he
handled uber's response to the hacking
he's accused of criminal obstruction and
he's pleaded not guilty
what happens to sullivan in this trial
is being closely watched by his peers in
the cybersecurity space
joining us to discuss the trial and its
implications is wsj cyber security
reporter robert mcmillan
hi bob thanks for joining us yeah great
to be here
bob companies are hit with hacks and
ransomware attacks pretty often these
days so what makes prosecutors allege
that in this case a crime was committed
well in this case there was an ftc
investigation going on so companies
aren't necessarily always under the
scrutiny of the federal government when
they get hacked and the feds want
everybody to know to be on notice that
they're taking this stuff seriously so
the allegations here are that mr
sullivan
basically engaged in a series of
behaviors that ultimately misled the ftc
about what was going on with
cyber security at uber and specifically
they're saying he paid some hackers a
hundred thousand dollars to make a data
breach go away
which is definitely a no-no now mr
sullivan's side of the story is
look it we get security problems
reported all the time there's this thing
called a bug bounty where we just pay
outside researchers to report issues to
us and we felt that
the data was not you know leaked we had
control of the data and we just sort of
funneled this notification of a problem
into our bug bounty program and resolve
the issue with no risk to consumers
i think the trial is interesting even if
you're not super into cyber crime or
cyber security but you know for those of
us who are maybe less aware of how these
systems kind of work can you explain
what a bug bounty is because i think
that's kind of the crux of what's going
on here did he pay a bug bounty or did
he pay ransom
so in olden times hackers would find
problems with people's software or
websites and they would just out of the
goodness of their heart many times try
to get them fixed or else they would
maybe exploit them for
for fun or profit you know there are
sort of two ways people could go with
this kind of security information and a
few years ago the tech company started
realizing like hey we could incentivize
these hackers to just quietly report
these issues to us and fix them but we
need to give them some incentives so in
the olden days it was like you get a
t-shirt for reporting a bug but hacking
has become big business and so
companies are paying out hundreds of
thousands of dollars now
for security information if you find a
bug that's truly devastating to the you
know apple iphone you can make a lot of
money with that information so this sort
of
gray kind of business has evolved where
people have you know they're sort of
poking around on your website they find
a problem and well they could hack in or
they could sell it to you know a nation
state that could then hack into this
company or they could report it to the
company and make some money
how do the decisions to pay out a sum
like this typically get made in a
company
well there's no question that in this
case it was an unusual decision so the
biggest bug bounty whoever had paid up
previous to this incident was ten
thousand dollars and suddenly they're
paying out a hundred thousand dollars
ten times what they've paid before so
this decision we know from corp records
that it went up to the ceo level
sullivan and the ceo discussed it the
payment decision can be just sort of an
automatic thing it doesn't have to be
discussed at that level you know you set
up the program and you have the
parameters of what you're going to be
paying and it doesn't have to be a ceo
level call
to pay you know ten thousand dollars for
a bug but this case was a little unusual
and so that's actually one of the things
that the prosecutors are pointing out
and drawing attention to
so who have we heard from so far in this
trial and how has that shaped either
side's argument through the court case
we're going to hear from
uber's security team the incident
responders the people that were dealing
with this problem and according to mr
sullivan's team there are more than 30
people who were in the loop about what
was going on there we're also going to
hear from the legal team the ones who
are interfacing with the ftc
and making the decisions about what to
tell them
and on friday uber's ceo testified about
the breach
basically he said he was hired in august
of 2017 and when he took over he
kind of took a look at what was said
about this incident and he
lost confidence in joe sullivan he felt
like he couldn't trust what sullivan was
telling him so that's why he fired him
okay the cyber security community is
watching this case pretty closely what
are the implications they're worried
about so the sullivan case is really
being watched very carefully by a lot of
security executives because he's facing
jail time for making a decision that i
think they have a lot of sympathy with
this like you have got a lot of pressure
when you're in that position
and the calls that get made you know
they involve a lot of people we're
talking about the ceo
the legal team and the security team all
in concert kind of making the decisions
on what to say to the ftc and how to
respond to this breach
and you're the security guy's the one
facing jail time so
there definitely is a contingent of
people who work in this business who
really think
that mr sullivan
should not have been charged right
because he had a hard job he had to make
a call
and um
you know they really have sympathy for
the pressure he was under now there's
another group of people who say like
look at it's obviously a data breach
when somebody gets the data and
downloads it from your company you got
to disclose that and why didn't that
happen
all right that was wsj cyber security
reporter robert mcmillan bob thanks
always for joining us great to talk to
you all
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]
you